[Applause]
ah
thank you thank you
the title of this talk is uh is our
studio 2022 but the actual subject of
the talk uh is to consider the question
of what would it take for us to give
this same talk uh in 2122. that's what
we're going to try to consider here
today and to do that
um
we want to start by reflecting back a
little bit on where we've been I want to
point out now that if you go to a Tech
conference and the founders are on stage
and they say we have some exciting news
and the first slide says our journey so
far is the 95 chance the company's
getting acquired so that that is not at
all what's happening today
um and that will never happen so yeah
that might have occurred to some of you
so anyway
um we are feel incredibly blessed to be
part of this community and you know the
company started 13 years ago but many of
us have actually been working on and
with our far longer than that and we've
built a set of tools and software that
helps people ask and answer the hardest
questions uh with code and a
reproducible fashion and all the while
creating an incredible Community which I
think if you're here today you feel if
you've been at past cons meetups all the
interactions we have online I think the
community we've built together is is
really remarkable
and also wanted to reflect back on kind
of what the most difficult problem we've
solved so far as a company and one very
obvious answer to this question and it
is a difficult problem is that we've
made our usable and productive and
approachable for many many many many
people many more people than probably
any of us thought would be possible and
that is a difficult problem it's a very
important problem it kind of enables all
the things I talked about on the first
slide but when me and Hadley and Joe and
others August
uh all got together about 10 years ago
and um said hey let's work on this
together for a long time I actually was
pretty confident that we would be able
to solve this problem
um but there's another problem that I
think we have we have solved which I
wasn't 100 confident we'd be able to
solve I hoped but I wasn't 100 confident
which is to create a sustainable model
for funding open source scientific
software scientific software is
traditionally created by large
proprietary software vendors kind of
necessarily so in a way because it's
actually there's a lot of software to be
written
a lot a lot of people depend on it
um but we really felt strongly that we'd
like to find a way to make open source
offer for science
sustainable
and reflecting a little bit on why this
problem matters I think actually
everyone here has a pretty good
intuition about why this problem matters
and and that was a subject of of the
talk I gave a couple years ago
okay
okay
use this instead okay great
uh as a subject of a talk I gave a
couple years ago uh reflecting a little
bit on kind of the most important
dimensions of that the scientific
process and the scientific uh method
depends on replication and
reproducibility and fundamentally if I
can't run your software either over
space you know a colleague another
company or another country or another
University or over time if I can't run
your software I can't reproduce your
work and I can't build on your work so
having the fundamental software be free
and open source kind of ensures or it at
least creates the the conditions for
widespread reproducibility and
replicability and also resiliency
software does die companies die versions
of products die things get out of
fashion open source software has that
fundamental right to Fork which means
that software can it can persist even
beyond the the the the the time period
over which its main sponsors are working
on it and then finally purchase
dissipation you've seen with crayon tens
of thousands of packages addressing all
different uh domains methodological
approaches and having the user community
be part of building the tools and
deciding what methods are supported is
fundamentally better than the idea of a
single vendor a couple vendors being a
choke point sort of deciding what
analytic analytic methods people are
going to be able to use with software so
I think this problem matters matters a
great deal to to science data science
science the future of science
and so when we think about the solving
this problem of sustainable funding for
open source scientific software there's
a few dimensions of the problem some of
it has to do with just the mission of of
the entities that are working on it some
of it actually has to do with the way
incentives are aligned around the work
and then and then even if you have those
things right getting to a certain scale
of effort is actually another threshold
condition
companies like uh Wolfram and MathWorks
and SAS you know employ hundreds of
people to work on scientific software
and I think something along that those
lines is is probably necessary to do it
really well with open source
so first kind of the corporate charter
and again we talked about this a couple
years ago at conf and it's important to
note that when we became a public
benefit Corporation we actually encoded
our mission into the corporate charter
and it actually is is the case that our
directors and officers have a fiduciary
duty to pursue this Mission
um and that mission when we wrote it I
think about three years ago is actually
written you'll notice here pretty
broadly we talk about free and open
source software for data science
scientific research and Technical
communication and partly even at the
time we were exclusively focused on data
science we sense that the kind of model
we were building might have broader
application and we wanted the mission
statement to reflect that so that's the
charter but then there's incentive
structures
um I would say that many or most uh
software companies
and technology companies have kind of
the the the seeds of their own demise
planted in them in them from the
earliest days startup companies often
exist to be really exist to be acquired
and once they're acquired all kinds of
things happen to their software and
their mission their people
um
even public companies who are not
acquired who are nominally independent
are really there's a pretty Narrow Lane
they have to exist in which is to always
grow always grow their revenue always
grow their earnings kind of at the
expense of everything else and that
certainly also causes the missions to
drift and so the thing that I'm really
pleased about with our studio is that we
actually are an independent company
we're committed to always being an
independent company and the control of
the company lies inside the company
people who work at our studio
fundamentally control the company it's
not controlled from the outside so we we
actually can say we're not going to be
we're going to continue to be
independent we can follow through on
that and for us our imperative we
certainly would like to grow but it's
not growth at all costs and it's never
at the expense of our core Mission and
so our hope maybe it's a little
optimistic
but we'd like to be here fulfilling that
mission in 100 years we're certainly
going to think as if we are or try to
um and make our work and Company be
organically sustainable
and then finally there's a there's a
question of scale of effort
um and I'm really happy about the fact
that uh about 40 percent of our
Engineers work full-time on open source
software this is a list of some of our
open source projects and the number of
full-time Engineers that work on them as
a as of now
um that's 43 Engineers but there's more
than that we actually have dozens of
people at the company who are not
full-time open source software Engineers
who also write packages and contribute
to open source projects so there's many
more than the 43 but there's 43 who are
paid to do nothing but work on open
source software 43 is great I hope in
five years that's going to be 143. and I
hope in 10 years that's going to be 200
or 300 and I think that represents an
opportunity to create a scale of effort
that is really remarkable and actually
presents an opportunity
um talking a little bit about how we
kind of got to this scale what the basic
mechanic is and and I think I I talked
about this a couple years ago too I'll
briefly recap recount it
um
there's a virtuous cycle synergistic
relationship between our open source and
our commercial software we write open
source tools that are accessible to
everyone they're accessible to anyone
independent of their economic means and
their their really useful as they are
without purchasing anything
but what happens is that inevitably when
lots and lots of people adopt open
source software some of that software is
is adopted in complex environments
larger organizations that have security
or scalability or integration
requirements people want to use the soft
deploy the software and use the software
on the web and that creates an
opportunity for us to create commercial
products which then help grow the
company and allow us to invest back in
our open source tools now
I want to tie this back a little bit to
the stuff about Mission and incentives
you'll notice there's a line here
there's a line between open source and
Enterprise products and a company and
we've seen this uh we've seen
historically companies whose in
principle imperative is growth at any
cost actually have an incentive to move
that line over time and what I think is
great about what we've done because we
have in the independence is that we
actually have an operative principle for
what's open source and what is not and
that is really that the core
intellectual property that you create
the reports applications analyzes code
that is all based on open source uh
packages protocols file formats and even
the core productivity tools like our
studio are open source so that anyone
can use them and then when we get into
these scenarios of more complex
environments that's when or deployment
on the web that's when commercial
software comes into play but we will
always respect that line and never
compromise that line for the sake of you
know of uh boosting our growth for any
given year or period of time
and I apologize actually I don't think
the type here is going to it's going to
be super legible people past the 10th
row but this is just kind of a picture
of the company over time kind of how
this has played out in 2009 it was one
person four years later in 2013 there
were six people
just working on open source software and
then about five years into the company's
life we decided that we'd like to try to
grow this group and do more as you can
see we started introducing some
commercial products that actually worked
and we became profitable very quickly
and we've managed to grow really really
substantially since then and create a
lot of this is just this is only some of
the open source software that we've
created and as you can see also we we've
managed to fill in additional commercial
products for all the different scenarios
that people have and that these things
again are sort of feeding each other and
allow us to get to this scale of you
know roughly now about 250 people in the
company and and and and dozens and
dozens of people working full-time on on
open source software so where does this
leave us
um we talked about that's kind of our
studio 2022 and we talked about where do
we go in the future and I think what's
remarkable to me is that we have
actually built this company that can
have open source software for science at
its core and it's able to fulfill that
mission as an independent company
and we're able to to employ lots and
lots of people
work on open source software and the
potential to employ many many more but
when we wrote that mission we included
scientific research and Technical
communication and as you you've probably
already seen
um with Cordo which you'll hear more
about tomorrow we're starting to work in
that realm of scientific communication
it certainly overlaps with data science
but it goes significantly Beyond it so
we've been asking ourselves the question
really when we started we worked on that
mission and we worked on quarto you know
do we have the potential does the
company have the potential to impact the
practice of science more broadly than
just the practice of data science with r
and I think the fact that we wrote the
mission that way the fact that you a lot
of the things you've seen us working on
over the last couple years to me the
answer to that is pretty decisively that
we can and we should do that
so to sum up
we think we've got a really good
foundation towards a sustainable model
for funding open source scientific
software and we want to do that by
creating this this long-term thriving
trustworthy company that's that's
hopefully going to be around 100 years
from now
and a hundred years is a long time
like programming has only been around
for 70 years data science charitably has
been around for 30 years
the languages today like Aaron Julia and
python are they going to be popular even
in 30 years or 50 years let alone 100
years so it's pretty clear that as much
as we individually love specific
programming languages to thrive in the
long term the mission of the company has
to be broader than that
and I think you can kind of see that
today already like one language is not
enough for most data scientists because
most data scientists have to use SQL and
something else and many teams use a
combination of R and Python and as soon
as those teams want to interrupt with
the rest of the company even more
languages come onto the table
and we believe this is like a this is a
fundamental property of of software like
there's never going to be one language
to rule them all and so the best tools
have to take this this into account and
I think we're already seeing this in an
open source tools like torch and
tensorflow which are tools for doing
deep learning machine learning where you
express your model in a human friendly
language a language designed to interact
with humans like r or python in behind
the scenes your model is is is is
converted into something very high
performance
will stand very similar to torch and
tensorflow but more statistical uh
statistical Computing environment really
helps fit many Bayesian models you
define your model in a high level
language like r or python or stator or
Matlab and then behind the scenes that's
converted to something very performant
or Arrow by our friends at Voltron data
an arrow is a data format designed so
that different languages can collaborate
on like literally the same data in
memory so there's none of those kind of
expensive copying or transforming that
that the different languages can
collaborate on exactly the same data set
and we're very much inspired by r r is
not a language like driven by purity of
its philosophy R is a language designed
to get [ __ ] done
and it's been this it's been like this
from day one yes the precursor was
designed by statisticians at Bell Labs
who had all these little Fortune
programs that each tackled a little bit
of the the data science or the
statistical analysis problem but they
needed some toolkit to join them
together so R from day one has always
been about building bridges combining
tools to get things done
and even our pro products are kind of
already multilingual like our studio
workbench of course it supports our
studio Ade but it also supports Jupiter
notebooks Jupiter lab and visual studio
code
our studio connect of course it can
deploy shiny apps and our markdown
documents but it can also deploy jupyter
notebooks and flask apis and dash and
streamline apps our studio package
manager is not just about our package
it's also about python packages
but there's something about those names
like our studio was a great name for the
company when our one product was
literally a studio for writing our code
but over the last few years that name
has started to feel increasingly
constraining
so today
very excited to announce that our studio
is becoming
[Music]
posit
[Music]
Ive so posit is a real word admittedly
it's a bit of an obscure word but it
means to put forth an idea to pretend
that something is true so that you can
argue about it
and this is like literally what data
scientists do they posit hypotheses so
that they can test or evaluate them with
data
so why do we like this name well it's a
real word uh and it's authentic like
it's literally what you all do
it's specific it's not some like gabori
gurk series of letters that could mean
anything but it also feels kind of
generic enough to last us for a long
time to come
and if you know anything about my uh
personal package naming philosophy
you'll also know it makes me very happy
that it's exactly five letters long
foreign
so as well as the new name our posit we
have a new logo which evokes the kind of
the greater than or less than symbols of
statistics and Mathematics the angle
brackets of HTML they're greater than
sign that you see the console all the
time but also this idea that weaving
together different tools different
languages different environments
different skills is stronger than they
are alone
so how do we get this name uh it was a
lot of work we partnered with a branding
agency who did a lot of research talking
to our studio employees our customers
community members trying to figure out
like who we are as a company what's our
DNA then that went on to a bunch of
brainstorming I think they brainstormed
over 500 names that got weirded down to
about 80 which we looked at we
shortlisted about five kind of sat on it
for about a week but posit very very
quickly kind of rose to the top
so what does this mean
well for our pro products not much as I
said they'll already support multiple
languages then they're not really going
to change but hopefully now it's a
little bit easier to tell that
multilingual story if you're an eye user
embedded in a python heavy team or org
hopefully it's a little bit easier to
get your colleagues to take a look at
posit than it would be to get them to
take a look at our studio
and over time in the coming months the
names of our products will change
deposit connect posit workbench posit
package manager and so on
what about for open source
well the IDE is already multilingual not
just R and python but it supports C and
C plus plus and JavaScript and HTML and
a bunch of other stuff keep doing that
but we're also going to increase our
investments in Visual Studio code
for our markdown it is evolving to
quarto you're going to hear a lot about
quarto at this conference I highly
recommend you come back tomorrow for
Julie and Mina's keynote which is going
to be all about quarto but basically
very very briefly Corto is like our
markdown but designed from the
foundations to be multilingual not just
IR or python but any language that might
come along in the future
the Tidy models mlvis and email Ops
these are already fundamentally about
connecting different systems and
languages and paradigms that will keep
going just be more of the same
the shiny well that is a very good
question and if you want to find out the
answer uh you'll have to wait for Joe's
keynote this afternoon
what about the Tidy verse well I still
believe that R is the best language for
interactive data science we're not going
to stop investing in it I will you know
learn a little bit about python but I'm
not going to stop stop writing archives
but of course we're also going to
broaden our focus a little bit start
thinking start doing little experiments
about how we can help folks in other
language communities and you can expect
us to hire more people who are
multilingual
now most importantly uh the question
you've all been asking yourself what
does this mean for stickers well uh most
excitingly if you look underneath your
seat uh there is both it's really wedged
under there so you might have to do this
after the talk but uh you'll find not
only a new posit sticker but also kind
of a commemorative R Studio sticker to
uh support to to recognize the name that
stood us instead for so long
foreign
[Laughter]
[Applause]
lucky audience member will also find a
Golden Ticket uh which is a free
registration to the conference next year
we're still pausing for excited hunting
yeah
so
Hadley talked a little bit about you
know the current projects we're working
on and where those stand and what you
can expect to see over the next couple
of few years but I wanted to address a
very very big picture where are we going
long term and I think you can just look
at our mission and see that we've
written it with a much broader scope
than data science and we would as we
grow we would like to apply this
solution to to funding open source
scientific software as broadly as we can
now that said uh we are very decisively
oriented toward data science today and
that that will not change anytime soon
you can see in quarto which overlaps
with data science but also kind of gets
into a broader focus on scientific
communication we'll be investing in that
quite a bit but I would say
um for the next five or ten years I
think this is the areas of investment
you're going to see us work within now
over time over a longer period of time
we'll certainly be looking for
opportunities to do more and contribute
more we don't know what that looks like
right now but we'll definitely be on the
on the lookout for it
and so kind of going back to our journey
and revising the language a little bit
to be to be phrased a little more
generally to talk about science uh for
me uh and for my colleagues at our
studio and the company I hope for all of
you and the broader our community I am
very excited about the opportunity to
take all the things that we love about
our in our studio and bring them to
everyone that's what I'm really excited
about so I hope we can all hope we can
all do that together we don't have a
website yet for the new company but this
is a there's a little bit of a
placeholder website you'll see you'll
see there thanks JJ
foreign